And the answer to that question of course is a little more subtle.
So there's two reasons why that doesn't work.
The first reason is a very formalistic one. The RAM can only handle integers.
Or at least the RAM cannot handle numbers with an arbitrary precision
because having an arbitrary precision is exactly the same thing as having
an infinite amount of values available for each variable.
And we said that the RAM doesn't support that.
And actually your computer also doesn't fully support that.
So you might be working with numbers such as 1.2345 or so,
but these numbers are always rounded numbers.
So also your computer does not have arbitrary precision.
It' s pretty well thought out normally how your computer handle such numbers
which is why we normally don't notice but in general
there's no arbitrary precision for your computer also.
Secondly, the table size wouldn't change. So we're not allowed to do this.
But let's say we're allowed to do this and then represent all of the values in the table exactly.
Then, the table size itself wouldn't change because you start out with a table that has
1, 2, 3, 4 and so on until you get to the columns.
And now in your new table, you would just have the same amount of columns
only the columns would be labeled 1/v, 2/v, 3/v, 4/v until you get to 1.
The third and the fourth are not valid reasons.
Just because then P would be NP is no counterargument against this.
And of course, as I've just shown you, that is also not true.
But asking this question here leads us to something else.
What if we were to divide all values by some number, which I'm going to specify to you,
and then round it down.
By rounding, we do two things.
So by rounding, we would make numbers that the RAM can handle.
And also in the case of rounding, the table size would change.
So let's say you had a table that looked like 0.5, 1, 1.5, 2, 2.5, 3, and so on.
Then, you could always put two columns together. So these two.
Except for the first one. That would become 0. But all the others you can put together.
So those two would become column 1. Those two would become column 2.
If you have 3.5 here, they would become column 3 and so on.
So you would be able to scale down the table but of course the whole thing comes at a price.
Because scaling down the table means that you put two columns together
only taking the minimum of it and therefore possibly arrive at a suboptimal solution.
Because certain objects where one object has a slightly higher value than another one
become indistinguishable using this technique.
Well, we're not going to divide by V. We're going to divide by some factor.
Dividing all values by a certain factor is a good idea but we have to round and this gives us an error.
Now, if you take a close look at this, you can almost see the approximation algorithm
emerging here because what happens when this factor here becomes very large?
Well, then we scale down the table that we build a lot.
So here we have n and here we have v.
If we divide all values by some large factor and of course we have to round,
then this table here becomes very small but of course our error also increases.
And if this factor here is very small, which means we almost keep all of the original table,
well then our running time is still very large but the error that we make is potentially smaller.
So this is exactly where the time and quality tradeoff will come from.
Let's now have a look at that in more detail.